The story took place in the late 1930's, during the Spanish Civil War.
A guerrilla group, led by Pablo, was behind enemy lines.
Robert Jordan was an American explosives expert.
He was assigned to blow up an enemy bridge.
Pablo was against this plan and Jordan worried that Pablo would betray them.
Jordan met Maria, a beautiful Spanish girl, and they immediately fell in love.
All guerrillas wanted to kill Pablo, but Jordan did not want to.
Pablo's wife Pilar told of how Pablo arranged a massacre.
Pablo left the group, then returned, and Jordan realized that he could not trust Pablo.
Jordan shot an enemy soldier who came to camp.
Some of the guerrillas, led by El Sordo, kept the enemy's horse,...
...then went out to look for more.
El Sordo's men were ambushed by the enemy and killed.
Through all of this, Jordan and Maria took the time to discuss their future.
Jordan sent a young guerrilla to General Golz with news of El Sordo's defeat...
...and a request that the offensive be canceled.
The message did not reach General Golz in time.
Pablo stole some dynamite and disappeared.
He returned later with five men and Jordan became confident they could accomplish their mission.
At dawn the next day, they blew up the bridge.
Many of the guerrillas were killed, including Jordan's guide and friend.
Jordan was injured when his horse fell on his leg.
Despondent, Maria tried to convince Jordan to allow her to stay with him, but he refused.
While the others escaped, Jordan stayed behind, to delay the advancing enemy.